Avec le temps j'ai réalisé médicalement que
les dommages causés à ma famille
pas mes enfants
a ma mère
parce qu'en eux-mêmes ce sont eux qui
ils se sentaient plus mal que moi et ça me fait mal
non pourquoi
c'étaient eux qui étaient touchés ils étaient petits
et
[Musique]
ici
et
pour
Yo
Oh
convient aux personnes qui ont le
situation économique précaire
les gens qui vivent des choses comme ça
non alors besoins économiques
alors ils cherchent ils voient qui
dans ce cas le cas c'était moi alors
ce
Eh bien, ils ne se soucient pas de ce qu'ils font
ils veulent gagner
[Musique]
et
Oh
Yo
ils ont besoin d'un évent
et puis ils me racontent leur vie
histoires leur tristesse aussi leur
bravo tes espoirs
cette année
en elle ou ton nom est une tentation
[Musique]
il
homme
et
s'ils se comportent